rich eisen had steve kyme the guy who
got the deal done
financially on the rich housing show
yesterday here's steve kim talking about
the recruitment
of justin james watt so
so that happened um almost immediately
in terms of viewing the game film
how long has there been an offer on the
table from arizona
to him that he said yes to steve well i
mean it was you know
first offer was i think after a few days
and
again really uh when you look at jj's
history i mean the guy's never been
recruited you know a walk-on in central
michigan and
um the path that he's taken i think it
was probably fairly exciting for him to
to have a number of teams recruit him
i certainly pulled out all the stops
guys like our friend frank caliendo and
hop and
even your new jingle blake shelton
okay how did caliendo help how did
caliendo help
in this process he probably impersonated
john gruden and
said that steve kyle had interest and
made some sort of funny uh deal i don't
know that what he did but
he was my son's flag football coach and
a terrible one at that but
he um he uh lives right around the
corner from our facility and is a good
friend as you know so
he's always willing to help
that's great frank calindo is the closer
and it is officially official there he
is justin james with his pen
on the paper signing with the arizona
cardinals god i want to know what that
contract says
base salary signing bonus roster bonus
per game roster bonus i want to dig into
that
that that stuff i enjoy i know that i
may be the only one who does but it just
really
it's it's a quest pete says you are shut
up pete
hey hey pete's kids tell your dad to
shut the hell up
[Laughter]
but but uh but it tells me where the bs
is i'm always on the lookout for bs
after 18 years of practicing law that's
basically all you do is look for bs and
there's so much bs in the reporting on
these contracts i just want to know what
it's really worth i'm just curious what
it's really worth
whatever it is yeah whatever it is they
got it done blake shelton frank caliendo
that's awesome
kurt warner jim hart mel gray
great great uh uh dan deardorff oh
man cardinals from the past involved to
get jj watt to sign
not not not really but if you pull out
all the stops it's a great point he'd
never been recruited in his entire life
right yeah now i i don't think he was a
walk-on at central michigan i think he
went to central michigan because he
wasn't recruited by a big ten school and
walked on at wisconsin
the story about being the pizza delivery
boy and all of that
i do think he went to central michigan
on scholarship and played tight end
and wore number 82. yeah yeah and looked
nothing like he does today
well no no but that's you know again
there's a lot of stories like that or
guys that are like that that just you
know they continue to grow and become
you know neanderthal beasts late into
high school early college career and all
of that
and yeah it is unbelievable when you
look at pictures of him back at central
michigan to
compared to the human he is now uh
definitely
but but i think that is that's a really
cool story and
i think it just speaks volumes again to
how much they wanted them that that just
shows you i mean the fact that steve
kime was
you know getting caliendo involved in
all of that and and having you know
pulling out all the stops
uh there was a real wanting there and
i'm sure that jj watt really felt that
like we just talked about
and then that always makes things easy
as a player man when you know you're
going to a place that
likes you wants you believes in you it
allows you to
you know be yourself and they're just
it allows you to go out and play because
they know who you are you don't feel
like oh i gotta do this or
i gotta get a little better at this to
prove that you know he he
he has that instilled in him anyway so
now he's not gonna feel like he has to
prove that to certain people who don't
know him in the organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports